a boeing triple seven taking off from
kabul destination doha dozens of foreign
passport holders finally on route to
cities far from afghanistan
this has been a nervous wait these
people missed out on evacuation flights
but 10 days after us forces left kabul's
international terminal has reopened
i'm sorry
i can't cry anymore i've been crying
this morning
for many it was a hard decision to leave
family members behind not knowing when
they would meet again i couldn't take
them with me because they're not
citizens
but it was very hard for me to leave um
they were sleeping i couldn't stay by
yeah they just found out now
this is the first time the international
terminal has opened since the taliban
took control it was badly damaged in the
days after they entered kabul but now it
has been repaired and this is the first
commercial flight to take off with 170
people on board for all intensive
purposes this is a normal commercial
flight where you need a passport or
official travel documents to take off
this flight was free a test case before
scheduled international flights began in
earnest boarding passes were hand
written the taliban nowhere to be seen
when did
we start to live but
just today
we have time to go before it was
impossible
to bring the airport back online
required foreign help qatar has led
repairs and operations since u.s forces
left 10 days ago
it says we are not we're not speaking
about evacuation we're speaking about
the free passage
and this is not evacuation anymore i
think we want people to feel that this
is normal
qatar's technical and security teams say
they now have the airport 90
operational adding in many areas like
the air traffic control tower they had
to start from scratch
military flights are now a regular
occurrence laden with tons of
humanitarian aid
pakistan brought in its first aid
delivery on thursday while gulf nations
have provided an airbrush for the un and
others
our message to the whole world is that
they should continue their cooperation
and aid afghanistan this country has
just come out of war now there's
security and the airport is functional
but we are in need of humanitarian aid
with each day that passes more aid
arrives and more passengers depart
domestic carriers are returning to
normal operations between afghanistan's
main cities the pressure is now on
international carriers to do the same
and provide a gateway for those who want
to leave kabul behind
charlotte ballas al jazeera kabul